MALE SPEAKER: The Google Maps
API is more than just a map.
To prove that, we set out to
visit six developers on five
continents in just eight days.
We went to their offices, work
spaces, favorite pubs, and
even their living rooms to show
you who they are, what
drives them, and why they trust
the Google Maps API to
build the next generation
of the web.
ANDRE TANNUS: Welcome
to Sao Paulo.
My name is Andre.
RODRIGO HANASHIRO: And
my name is Rodrigo.
We founded Epungo.
IAN CUMMING: G'day.
I'm Ian Cumming.
I'm from Insight4 Labs.
And I'm the founder of
getflight.com.au.
MICHAEL PLETZIGER: Gutentag.
My name is Michael
Pletziger from
UbiLabs in Hamburg, Germany.
VACHARA AEMAVAT:
Sawatdee kraup.
My name is Vachara, and I'm
from Computerlogy and
developed an application
using Google Map API.
BERNADETTE NDEGE:
Hi, [INAUDIBLE].
My name is Bernadette Ndege.
I developed Google Maps
API for Upande.
MALE SPEAKER: What we found
was a vibrant community of
developers, creating amazing
applications.
RODRIGO HANASHIRO: We are a
technology startup business in
Sao Paulo, Brazil and focuses
on the real estate market.
IAN CUMMING: GetFlight lets
people [? wind ?]
and search for cheap airfares
in Australia and
view it on a map.
VACHARA AEMAVAT: Computerlogy
has to use Google Maps API to
help people find ATMs and save
people from fraud in Thailand.
MICHAEL PLETZIGER: You can see
our developers working on
Google Maps-based
applications.
We work for clients such as BMW,
Dodge Telecom, Swiss Post
but also for nonprofit
organizations.
ALLAN PANOSSIAN KAJIMOTO:
Because it's a social, local
guide, we are a place where
people can search for places
that they want, write about
it, find accommodations.
MALE SPEAKER: You're invited to
come along with us and meet
these innovative developers on
their home turf, as they show
us how a map can be more
than just a map.